elaine what do you say
well i don't think so erin uh uh
i have plans
oh
how about you jerry
i'm
sorry up close
maybe i'll try and catch up with you
that's the classic scene from seinfeld
the episode involving a close talker the
show was all about the unwritten rules
of social interaction well good news for
you those rules they have now been
written down in a new book and check out
the title it's called cues master the
secret language of charismatic
communication with some guidelines on
how not to be awkward it's by the
best-selling author and researcher
vanessa van edwards she joins us right
now first on cbs mornings how are you
doing good morning so good thanks for
having me we won't be talked we will be
close okay we're far away we have our
distance right now
now you write if if you want confidence
and to be taken seriously
then you have to follow the right cues
what are those cues okay so a queue is a
social signals humans send to each other
right so any of those social signals
we're sending 17 years ago i began this
research and i noticed that highly
charismatic people didn't matter if they
were athletes or celebrities or
politicians or business leaders showed a
specific set of cues and i wondered
could we codify them could we catalog
them and so charismatic people are
signaling constantly warmth and
competence and you're saying you can
catalog them and then teach them to
others you describe yourself as a
recovering awkward person do i have that
right yes i'm a recovering awkward
person so i always thought that charisma
was an innate trait you were either born
with it or you weren't but luckily
luckily
it can be cultivated with the right cues
and it's only the two so
what's special about charismatic people
the reason why we're so drawn to them is
because they signal two things at the
same time they have warmth cues
collaborative trusting open friendly but
at the very same time they're competent
capable powerful they get things done
and that's why they're so special they
have that secret sauce okay let's go
over so quickly some of your queues yeah
cause you say smart people steeple
what's that okay so you want to try it
with me yeah yeah yeah okay so just
you'll if you do this for a second you
actually kind of feel more put together
right and it can be a loose one so the
reason i call this a power pose for the
hands why you can see palms we love a
palm oh we love a palm we love to see a
becking over it's nice and loose it's
sort of put together yeah perfect who
says it shows confidence and confidence
that's right tilt the tilt okay so if i
were to say do you hear that we we tilt
our head to the side so the head tilt is
a
right we
[Laughter]
because it is a universal engagement
queue when i'm saying oh tell me more
i'm literally showing i'm listening
i do this one a lot too does this want
to help like so this is the pensive
right that's why we know this is the as
the thinker it's pencil doesn't sound
good well
well
you have to be careful you have to be
careful not to touch your face and
here's why
liars are found to touch their face more
often yeah touch their nose touch their
nose they itch their nose right i'm not
going to do it i'll ruin my makeup but
they itch their nose or they cover their
mouth or they rub their eyes you want to
actually avoid any mouth nose eyes okay
you also said vanessa you should show
warm cues in the first three minutes of
interaction when you meet somebody yes
so here's what the research finds one
two three one two three is we have to
show warmth so a palm the moment i'm on
camera or i walk into a room where i'm
on video call good morning how are you
come on over so we love a palm we love
that head tilt right and we also love
the right distance no clothes talking
right so we like that social zone
especially on video you want to be
careful on video
eyebrow raise oh the eyebrow raised so
think about this when i want to see more
i want my eyebrows to get out of the way
so i can take in more you'll notice if
you're across a bar and someone goes
right you know what that is i think
they're weird i think
i think they're weird
that's when i give them the palm as well
it's like this is like hello
hell they're just shooting their shots
with their eyebrow right there it's a
beckoning call there's fun stuff in the
book too because you said inflection
matters which is why people when they're
talking to babies raise their voice and
say oh you look so cute to dance okay so
the higher voice the higher pitch means
i'm approachable i can do this but when
we're down here we're nice and low it
means we're taking things seriously the
issue is the up talk or the question
inflection so if i were to come on and
say hi my name is vanessa i'm happy to
be here let's talk about cues it's
actually giving away my vocal power but
that doesn't show confidence so what if
i say hi my name is nate i'm happy to be
here that's it that's it because sales
people like if you ever mention a number
and you say my cost is five thousand
dollars
uh-huh would you accept it you're
telling someone negotiate with me i
don't know it's five thousand dollars
all right so we're talking about
physical cues but a lot of people are on
dating apps they're not even getting to
the physical part they're in cyberspace
what can you tell them okay so for
dating apps one is you have to make sure
you have the right verbal cues and i
like verbal cues that social signal okay
so i like queues if you're going to say
hi in an app don't just say hi how are
you right hi how are you is autopilot i
like cues that wake people up so a howdy
an aloha oh ready howdy what's good
right instead of how are you like what's
good what's right like what's up
because then you're asking the brand
wait i gotta write that
[Laughter]
nonverbal cues either enhance or detract
that's right nonverbal cues are huge yes
so remember that 90 percent 65 to 90 of
our communication is non-verbal the
problem is we show up to our interviews
our pitches our dates with perfect
verbal right we practice the verbal but
if i were to say yeah i'm so happy to be
here
right you would know based on my
nonverbal even the verbal so i want
everyone to practice their delivery that
the non-verbal aspect of how we deliver
our verbal is just as important as the
verbal and colors make a difference
colors
let me see if uh i can oh this can make
you rich as well if you can as well i
mean it's going to help you
professionally let me see if i can apply
what i learned okay vanessa van edwards
thank you thank you okay q's is on sale
today wherever you like to buy your
books